hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
just checking in
checking in on you
just checking in on you what's going on
how are you
oh billy quiet face
in his hotel room out on the [ __ ]
road
uh getting ready to do
pittsburgh and then nashville and then
columbus
and then cleveland and then chicago
with joe bartnick for his special
so um
yeah i got all of that [ __ ] to do and
you know what i'm in boston right now by
the time you hear this i'll be in
pittsburgh though
um
flying out tonight there
um
what's it gonna say i was [ __ ]
walking around boston today
i went to the red sox game the other
night right and i wanted to get a couple
of hats
um
and i wanted the ones like the the
fitted ones
the stretchy fitted ones right so i go
to the to the
whatever the [ __ ] store you go to
that i've been going to since i was a
little kid
and uh i got that marathon one and i got
the the regular one
you know i'm trying on the sizes or
whatever and i get back to my [ __ ]
hotel room and neither one of them fits
me one of them's too big the other one's
too small it's like what the [ __ ] i
tried them out
and when i realized when i went back to
the store
is that people try them on and then they
just yeah that doesn't fit they just put
it back anywhere because people don't
give a [ __ ]
so i went oh for two on those so i had
to go back today
and i um
i ended up uh
you know i always got to make a trip to
the north end
at some point
and you know i'm editing that movie from
the road so i didn't have a lot of time
so i was like you know what why don't i
get the gym out of the way as far as my
walk so i walked from fenway
all the way you know kenmore square all
the way down comm ave
government center to uh
the north end by the swan boats and all
that was such a great walk
and um
saw a bunch of college kids hanging out
in the park having a good time
and then i saw parents with kids and
stuff
it was really cool and uh i learned a
lot on the walk
you know i was sitting there i learned
that i'm not young anymore which i
already knew but i always keep learning
that
then
i saw this woman
i think she was on the freedom trail and
she had like these kids who were like
under the age of 10
and she's just sitting there reading
them all this [ __ ] about [ __ ] paul
revere
and these poor kids
could just give a [ __ ]
and they're not retaining any of the
information and i'm just sitting there
looking at her like you know you're
doing a good thing
you're combating you know ipads and tvs
and the screen you're com
trying to com combat that [ __ ]
and like but i got to be honest if this
is the option
that they go from a [ __ ]
flat screen tv or an ipad
to listen to you telling them where
[ __ ] paul revere you know rode his
goddamn horse and it took a [ __ ] or
whatever the hell you do like these kids
could not have given a [ __ ]
less and she was just plowing through
this information looking at it on a um
on like a brochure
i learned something i was like i'm not
doing that with my kids we're not going
on vacation to learn something
we're not we're going on vacation to be
on vacation i'm not going to [ __ ]
take you to seattle
and then be like and and this is where
uh you know [ __ ] kurt cobain
rode a horse to get a [ __ ] sandwich
you know whatever the [ __ ] they do out
in seattle
um i'm not doing that
i'm just going to chill out and we're
going to have a good time
like i feel like teaching kids you got
it you got to like you got to sneak it
in
you know you can't just come at i'm like
yeah you're gonna shut out you're gonna
learn this [ __ ] first of all they
already get that at school
so if you come home
and you're gonna do that i [ __ ] hated
that when i was a kid
and some stupid adult would be telling
me
let's sit half a second i'm i'm i'm
going to teach you something
and the whole time
that they were talking i was i would
just oh are you you [ __ ] douche
that's all i was thinking and they
probably were telling me
you know
something i should have retained but
i don't know
the older i get in this just being being
a parent i just realized just some of
these [ __ ] people you can learn so
much like good [ __ ] too but he goes to
learn like i'm not doing that i'm never
taking my kids on the [ __ ] freedom
trail
in massachusetts i'm not doing that
there is no [ __ ] if they want to do
that when they're adults
they can do that or whatever but there
is no way
oh bill who's kidding who you can't sit
through it i couldn't there's no [ __ ]
i can't sit through it
there's certain historical events i can
sit through there's something about that
powdered wig [ __ ] i just i don't give a
[ __ ]
and i know it has a you know
it's an important part of the history of
this country but i just don't care
when people had buckles on their hats
and on their shoes i just i can't
i don't know what it is
there has to be like a certain level
of like
like i don't give a [ __ ] about world war
one
i don't give a [ __ ] about the fbi
i don't give a sorry um
i mean obviously you know that's
belittling the sacrifices and everything
i just don't i can't like sit down
that's not true because i read all quiet
on the western front and that was
amazing you know i need planes i need
machine guns
and bombs
and i can [ __ ] read about a war it's
weird
it's weird but if it's just like if
there's like horses involved
like i'm like ugh
unless it's like
you know cowboys and indian stuff when i
was growing up like the real story
not our story then i can get into this
[ __ ]
all right you know what i realized in
the last [ __ ]
seven minutes is i judge that mother
because she was saying some [ __ ] that i
didn't want to hear about
and then i just made it about her kids
not wanting to hear about it maybe i
should do it
i don't [ __ ] know anyway this is the
podcast
listen [ __ ] that i stand by the fact
that those kids did not give a [ __ ]
they did not give a [ __ ] about what she
was talking about they look [ __ ]
miserable
just give them an ice cream
they have their whole life
to sit and listen to another person
[ __ ] yammer in some [ __ ] that bores
the hell out of them that they have to
retain in order to get to the next
[ __ ] step in life
why do that to them when they're kids
yeah it's good training
that's good training
so anyway
um yeah oh billy big
billy billy ball game
i'm gonna be at fenway park i can't
believe it august 21st and i got a whole
bunch of tickets i need to sell so if
you were ever gonna take a road trip to
go see me i could use you on this one
um i went to the red sox blue jays game
on tuesday night i got to throw out the
first pitch and
the amount of [ __ ] people were giving me
like
people texting me out of the woodwork
call me up dude don't [ __ ] it up don't
do it
all of this stuff
i couldn't believe it and i just kept
laughing going like i'm a [ __ ]
comedian
whatever you do don't bounce it or else
what
like what's gonna happen were they gonna
sign me and now they're not
so
anyway
i show up at the ballpark
and they walked me in and i'm getting
butterflies
a little bit like back in the day when i
would do like letterman or something
and i was like wow i haven't felt that
in a minute
and i'm like that's never good
that's never good i got to get control
of that so when they brought me down to
the field
um
i just started shooting the [ __ ] with
people down there you know talking so i
wouldn't be thinking about what i had to
do
and then i played catch with one of the
ball girls down there
who made a great catch on one that i got
a little wild on and i almost hit this
whole group of women down there i don't
even know why they were there and then i
watched the news they found out they
want
this like back-to-back hockey
championships i saw him they had like
this trophy i didn't
wish i talked to him but i didn't i
ended up talking to the the the
choir that sang the uh
national anthem so
anyway
i threw a couple two tree i felt all
right and then they said all right you
know they announced the lineups and then
they they [ __ ] brought me out there
and i got to tell you the mound is it's
like it's not even like it's like no
dirt i've ever stood on in my life it
was like synthetic dirt
it was so perfect
you know it was funny
my buddy asked me goes what were you
doing
before he goes i saw you you like
reached down like almost like you're
reaching down for a rosin bag
were you writing something in the dirt
and i was like oh no i was
i had a wrapper from a breath mint fell
out of my pocket i put my hand in my
pocket and came out and i didn't want to
litter out there
so he thought i was doing some cool
[ __ ]
you know
sami sosa [ __ ] and i was just picked
picking up a breath mint wrapper from a
lifesaver a little clear plastic one if
you wanted to know what that was
and then i just went up there and i was
going to do this whole louis teon thing
i only did a little bit of it
and i just [ __ ] without thinking i
just [ __ ] before i overthought it
and i just aimed at the guy's head
it was funny my buddy said it had a
little action on it man he goes i you
know it kind of [ __ ] the bottom
dropped out of it and i said that was
that was it running out of velocity
[Laughter]
um
yeah so it went all right i threw a
strike thank god and then when i when i
threw the strike and it went good and
the crowd clapped
uh
i realized how much i gave a [ __ ]
because i went up there and i did what i
usually do
as i just downplay the whole thing
i give that [ __ ] just go up throw this
stupid [ __ ] thing no one gives a [ __ ]
if it bounces nobody's gonna care who
gives a [ __ ] it's not like they're gonna
add this to a compilation it's like
people make compilations of the worst
first pitches by people in the public
eye
which i found out they do
um i just downplayed the whole thing and
then when i actually do it and it's over
then i feel great and that's what
happened you know i wish i could have
been zen and ben in the moment i just
[ __ ] did it and then when it was over
i felt like i was 100 feet tall the rest
of the [ __ ] night
you know
oh god the level of [ __ ] i would have
got for that one so thank god thank you
and thank you to the red sox for uh
hooking me up with that
and let me tell my [ __ ] jokes there in
august but um
that's what i was telling
you know
my family was there obviously and i was
just like oh my god i go i can't believe
how much i gave a [ __ ] i'd literally
convinced myself that i didn't care
and then the second i threw it and it
didn't bounce and the guy caught it i
was like ah thank god
i did everything but twirl around and
throw my hat in here like [ __ ] marry
tyler moore
um and then i got to go up in the booth
on uh nesting with david uke and i had a
great time with them i got to do w-e-e-i
um before the game i got to do pbs and
do a little thing
and uh they said fred lin was in the
building that was the only thing i
didn't get to meet him but other than
that it was awesome
i still can't i'm like i don't have
anything funny to say about i'm just
[ __ ] stunned
that that even happened and then uh
next thing you know i was like
eating some food and the game's going
and i tell you what's cool the
scorecards now you don't even have to
fill out the lineup anymore that was the
big pain in the ass they'd be like
batting first so-and-so batting second
jd again slow the [ __ ] down you know i'm
trying to
fill this out now you get it it's
already all filled out the only thing is
they still have the pencil without the
eraser
and i always end up [ __ ] up you know
at the end of an inning
you know i'll go like two or two batters
three batters and realize that i'm
filling it out for the other [ __ ]
team that's the worst which is what i
did but the red sox won i hope they're
winning tonight i'm obviously i'm
recording this on wednesday
you know the big bad blue jays
who are talking smack like they're gonna
win the uh american league east so i'm
expecting
um they're gonna try to avenge that loss
tonight we shall see we shall see and
i'm gonna run my hour tonight
uh before my flight
and uh
other than that i don't know what else
i'm gonna do i got this whole tour i'm
gonna go into pittsburgh now this is
gonna be a tough tour for me to stay in
shape
because not only am i going to these
cities where i have friends like i know
their parents and their parents all cook
you know
you go to pittsburgh you're going to run
into the bartnicks
and joe bartnick's mother's going to
throw down
i mean pittsburgh you just i mean that's
3 000 calories a day
then you go to nashville not only is it
nashville it's also the south
so you got all of that going on and then
columbus i think i can do all right
and then cleveland
uh you know cleveland is cleveland
well you know what they have decent
restaurants downtown now i just always
that place always just feel like it's
like sports arenas
hilarities and a bunch of bars
with like you know
food you can eat when you're in your 20s
but um
anyway
so speaking of louis teont i actually uh
someone was telling me about this
documentary the lost son of havana
that they made about louis when he was
67
and he had left
cuba in 1961 uh right before the bay of
pigs
and they uh
closed down the borders and they told
all you know cuban baseball players that
were playing in america come back and
play in cuba or never come back and he
had yet to be back and it was this
really cool documentary about him going
back for the first time
it's up on youtube
in about four or five different parts
and
uh what i did love about it was every
time they showed louis tiant he was
smoking a cigar
and he's still alive he's like 82 i
think 81 82 years old and he was smoking
these things like
that was no tomorrow so
made me feel a little bit better about
some of my life choices there
um
oh i know what i wanted to tell you guys
when i was
down on the field the mascot wall-e came
up
you know he's
they do that weird mascot thing where
they don't talk and [ __ ]
you're like hey how's it going and they
got to do the whole shrug on the
shoulders like hey you know
you win some you lose some he's like
doing that little [ __ ] shrug kind of
thing
and um
then all of a sudden i see the female
version of him
and i'm like going like oh [ __ ] you got
yourself a girlfriend good for you wally
where'd you meet her and they still
start like
waving their hands
like that time that guy dressed like
bert for the sesame street was waving
his hands i thought he was saying hello
to me before he slammed the door in my
face they started waving their hands
like that and covering their eyes
and i'm like what what what what did i
say and somebody goes they're not
boyfriend girlfriend they're brother and
sister
and i was like oh [ __ ]
i'm sorry
didn't mean you grossed you out wally
and he's sitting there shrugging his
[ __ ]
shoulders and covering his eyes it was
[ __ ] hilarious
that i suggested incest between two
mascots and then they had to like play
it off like with mascot embarrassment
and then forgive me all while like
miming like i was in like this silent
film but i was the only guy talking it
was really weird
um
but i will tell you one of my favorite
parts of the night was being up in the
booth the nesting booth and that is
really something like
in another life
i would have done that
i would have done that for a living
and i actually think baseball would be
like the coolest one to do it for
you know
because that's the one that has like the
most
time to like shoot the [ __ ]
you know like one of my favorite things
like back in the day was listening to
two people [ __ ] during like a rain
delay
just having to talk for like two [ __ ]
hours
like they're like the original
podcasters just sitting there riffing
for two [ __ ] hours waiting for the
ump like dude would you just call the
games we all can we can all go drinking
oh let's just [ __ ] get a little wet
and get six innings in order five and a
half innings whatever the [ __ ] we have
to do here
um
but i had uh
i think there's really something cool
about being um
like a play-by-play person
like you just do like on the radio
i think is really cool
you know people like know your voice and
[ __ ]
they don't really know what you look
like so you can kind of just walk around
you know and if you don't want to get
recognized you just act like those
mascots you just cover your eyes and
shrug your shoulders when anybody asks
you
like a question or something
um
anyway
um i was facetiming with my kids today
and my son has this new thing like he's
he's into any sort of like truck a car
like he always whenever i whenever he
sees my car he goes he goes dada's cool
car
cool car
dada's cool car he does that's the best
right and anything he sees if he sees a
truck he goes cool car i go it's a truck
he can't say he can't make tr sounds yet
but his thing now is he's like
fascinated
with how all of these things work so all
of his toys that he pushes around toy
trucks and stuff
scooters or whatever
he now like tips them over
and he really looks at him he just sort
of spins the wheels and he's really like
trying to figure out
how they work he's such a little smart
guy
must have got it from his
from his mother i know god damn well he
didn't get it for me
but um
anyway why does this only say four
minutes that i only record for four
minutes
is that what this is trying to say
or did it start a new recording
i don't [ __ ] i think it started a new
recording
hold up all right yeah so accidentally
hit stop whatever i'll just edit i'll
just edit the [ __ ] thing together
dude um anyway so i had a great trip
back here uh to boston i got to see all
my nieces and nephews i did the whole
thing
and i am looking forward
to coming back here this summer and um
you know doing my show here which is
going to be crazy um and thank you to
everybody that's been buying tickets
tickets have been going
thank christ and uh
yeah there's that all right let's let's
do a little uh advertising here for this
week oh look who it is everybody it's
masterclass
you know with masterclass you can learn
from the world's best minds anytime
anywhere at your own pace learn to
barbecue
from aaron franklin skateboarding from
tony hawk we do this is ridiculous
they never had stuff like this learning
songwriting and producing from alicia
keys
unreal this is like when i started
comedy learn how to write a joke from
george carlin they didn't have stuff
like this you realize how good you guys
are going to get it all of this stuff
with over 100 classes from a range of
world-class instructors
that thing you've always wanted to do is
closer than you think masterclass is
accessible on your phone
web or smart tv talk about like using
the internet in the the proper way
to become a better more informed or just
you know have more fun this is what you
got to do something like this offering
classes on a wide variety of topics all
taught by world class masters at the top
of their fields it's such a great idea
each class is broken out into individual
video lessons usually around 10 minutes
long
members can explore at their own pace
and each class is supported by
downloadable materials lessons recipes
or more hundreds of video lessons from
100 plus of today's most brilliant minds
are available anytime anywhere on ios
android desktop apple tv amazon fire tv
and roku
um
i mean if you're i would i would check
out
if you want to learn how to play guitar
my thing
you know
i would check out any of the guitar
players that they have on there um
oh what they got what's his face there
tom morello teaches how to play guitar
sheila e teaches drumming and percussion
let me go into a category let's see here
let's try food
what do they got here
oh
gordon ramsay aaron franklin teaches
texas style barbecue that looks cool
um somebody teach me how to make some
goddamn pasta for once in my life
art of home cooking alice walters
all right you get the idea wolfgang puck
i mean you know back in the day you
actually had to be a good cook to talk
to these [ __ ] people now you can just
get on this thing
you know
and you're all set you're good to go get
unlimited access to every master class
and as a monday morning podcast listener
you can get 15 off an annual membership
go to masterclass.com
now that's masterclass.com
for 15 off masterclass all right
now who do we have we have helix helix
uh the most important thing you can do
is get a good night's sleep oh [ __ ]
i didn't do that last night your mental
health metabolism and energy all depend
on it helix sleep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete and matches
your body type and sleep preference to
the perfect mattress for you with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
down if you sleep hot gross mattresses
great for spinal alignment to prevent
morning aches and pains and even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers all
the big boys just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free they'll even pick
it up for you if you don't love it
but you will you'll love it at levitt's
helix even has a financial options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at
helixsleep.com that's
com slash helixsleep.com for up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
well guess what i'm excited about oh
what are you excited about there
freckles
what do you say there
um i am excited about the fact that uh
i got this thing to to help fix my
shoulders
i don't know what the hell you call it
oh jesus bill are you really gonna do
this
well this is what happens when you do a
stream of consciousness you start
talking about [ __ ] and you don't have
this
stuff in front of your need
um
i ordered these things oh it is the only
thing that gives orders
um
let's see shoulder is getting this might
be it
ah that's not it god damn [ __ ]
i don't know what the hell it is
i bought this thing on the internet
right it has a handle and has like a
like a little ball at the end of it and
you just spin it
with your arms straight out
clockwise then counterclockwise
you know this angle clockwise
counterclockwise and then straight to
the side of your body you know when you
do it for 40 days 10 days with each
little weighted ball and each one gets a
little heavier and it's supposed to fix
your shoulders and it's done wonders for
my shoulder
you know
that's why i was able to bring the 49
mile per hour heat last night from the
[ __ ] hill
um seriously i was able to throw it
and not hurt myself and um i'm in the
gym i'm i'm [ __ ] getting them uh
i was hanging from a chin-up bar the
other day so tempted
to try to do a rep but i know that that
would set me back months so
i'm just sticking with this [ __ ]
while i'm on the road
freckel douche i'm just going to keep uh
working out with this [ __ ] although i
the only thing that sucks about that
thing is i don't dare take it on the
road unless you check it because it's
gonna look like a medieval weapon
in your carry-on so the thing ain't
cheap
um
as far as ordering [ __ ] on the internet
i want to say it was a
a couple hundred bucks
but uh to have shoulders that [ __ ]
work again is fantastic and then i've
been doing this stretch
um where you you reach your arm up
behind your back and have your hand
between your shoulder blades and then
your other hand reaches over the top of
your shoulders
to grab your other hand you interlock
your fingers
now i can do that with one my
one side
with my left arm behind my back my right
arm
i have to give it a little bit of help
to get it up there i'm not quite there
but i just do it every single day
and um
because i have to win this bet i have
with versi
see he thinks it's over like i should
just give him the 200 bucks already but
i'm going to be able to do 10 pull-ups
by the time i'm 70. um i'm not saying
i want to forgive me the money if i do
do like a cycle
you know like all these actors that do
like the [ __ ] hghs so they can run
around in their underwear and be like a
superhero
i should really start teasing about that
because you'll end up seeing me
maybe one day
there's no redheaded superhero
oh no there isn't
what the [ __ ]
all we got is the joker sometimes he has
red hair he has like green hair wait a
minute is there no [ __ ] ginger
[ __ ] there's no ginger man there's
ginger bread man but he's not a [ __ ]
superhero he's a goddamn cookie
wait a second
ah jesus christ
ginger super hero
get the [ __ ] out there isn't
there's a woman
wait here's a guy
ginger superhero
no that's just somebody being an [ __ ]
a guy has like a [ __ ]
purple cod piece with like
fishnet stockings
there isn't
there is not
wait redheaded males
comic vine they just they don't exist
ah that guy doesn't have red hair it's
brownish orange
maybe this is why i never got into those
marvel movies you know what it was i
just didn't see me on the screen
you guys
do you have any idea how difficult it is
to go to a marvel movie and not see
yourself represented
i get my identity from superhero movies
um
anyway
you ever be in a hotel room you just
open the [ __ ] window up
you know and you just look across into
another hotel room you're like you're
just expecting to see two people [ __ ]
it never happens
it never happens
you're just like why do i do the road
what is the point
you know what i do is i look out the
window and i just look at the people
walking by so i just know if i need a
jacket or not that's the level of
excitement of being out on the road will
you look at that [ __ ] boat out there
is that why they do the uh do they still
do the boston tea party out here
stupid-ass [ __ ] tourists
reenacting that [ __ ] do you think that
even happened
i think there's a better chance of jesus
being white
then um
has that been proven yet
is jesus white
i wonder if he is i hope he isn't
it'd be good if he wasn't cause then we
don't have to deal with all of his
[ __ ] you know
be nice if his guilt trip was the
responsibility of a different race
i died for you man we got it we got it
you know thank you appreciate it didn't
really ask you to do it but now that you
did it
thank you you're gonna bring it up the
whole [ __ ] time jesus christ race
there's gonna be a bunch of people
dressed like jesus
running down the street
color of christ
a storm
this isn't the body of christ this is
the color of christ that's a [ __ ]
great name a story of race and religion
in america
uh
why does america only get [ __ ] for being
racist i don't understand it like every
every [ __ ] place you go to
you [ __ ] sit there act like it's a
goddamn utopia it isn't all right uh
what did jesus look like
uh the many different depictions of
christ
tell a story about race and religion in
america
edward j blum and paul harvey explored
that history in their new book the color
of christ the son of god and the saga of
race in america the book traces how
different races and ethnic groups
claimed christ as their own and our
depictions of jesus have both inspired
civil rights crusades and have been used
to justify the violence of white
supremacy
the coup
klux klan could not rely on christian
doctrine to justify their persecution of
violence so they had to turn to
religious icons the belief the value
that jesus is white provides them an
image in place of text
it gets them away from actually having
to quote chapter and verse which they
can't really do to present their cause
i sure they could people do that all the
[ __ ] time they just pick a chapter
and they have their own [ __ ]
interpretation of it
uh
all right when slave owners try to
christianize their slaves they bring
jesus in two forms one in is as a
servant
and that's to say hey look service is
good service is godly so your work is
your work service is good but they also
present jesus as master you have to
follow his lead to not lie not steal
i don't know about any of this [ __ ] this
is why i don't [ __ ] go to church
all right race and appearance of jesus
here we go
let's see he's pretty much like uh
a woodstock skateboarding looking dude
there was no scholarly agreement on the
appearance of jesus over the century
he's been
depicted in many ways yeah there's no
picture of the guy so like how do you
know what he looked like
yeah this dude this i hate to say it
guys it's a [ __ ] scam and he's not
coming back
[Laughter]
i am so sorry
why why would i why would i end on that
maybe he is
you know what don't get mad at me jesus
believers pray for me
all right that is it everybody that's
the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast i want to
thank uh
know
i don't know everybody involved that got
me to where i was at
that i got to throw at that first pitch
that was truly the coolest thing i ever
got to do and i still cannot believe
i still can't believe it it feels it
went by so fast it feels like a friggin
dream and i'm so happy i didn't bounce
the goddamn ball because i never would
have heard the end of it from you
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right that's the
podcast enjoy your weekend you [ __ ] uh
there'll be a little bit of music and
then a bonus version um
i'm sorry a bonus episode
of uh a thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast all right
that's it i'll see you go celtics
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
april 21st
2014
being recorded
live on digital tape
in the good old usma
in my [ __ ] bedroom
oh man it's great to be back well let me
tell you well i'll tell you i had a
crazy flight coming back y'all
no i am uh i'm excited to be back i'm
happy to be back uh i didn't want to
leave
but you know at some point you got to
grow up right go back to work
you know put some food in a [ __ ]
brown sack
get into some [ __ ] car that has a
hatchback
inch your way into traffic can i go can
i go thank you
thank you one person who cares
you know
put on jack fm
and sit there and cry as they call songs
that you thought came out two weeks ago
classics
girl it's been a long time since we've
been apart
that's the 40th anniversary get the [ __ ]
out of here
[Music]
some metalhead's gonna call oh actually
that came up 1981 go [ __ ] yourself all
right take off your rob halford leather
studded gloves and go clean out the
garbage disco disposal right why don't i
say garbage disposal because that's what
i think of when i think of those gloves
the ones that go all the way up to your
elbows
you know
basically the glove form of superhero
boots
um anyways this is the monday morning
podcast if you're new to the podcast uh
welcome thank you for listening i know
you have your choice between mine and
nine zillion other [ __ ] podcasts
i mean at this point i mean you guys
could all have a podcast but why would
you do that
why would you do that when you could
just sit down and listen to someone else
attempt to do it i don't [ __ ] know um
yes so
back in the united states and uh
i had an unbelievable trip you know what
[ __ ] story i kept
trying i kept forgetting to tell you
guys
and uh i'm not still boring you with
stories about france but i i did have a
[ __ ] great time over there um
which is an understatement
anyways i know like two weeks ago i told
you or last week i told you the story of
going to uh
omaha beach
and the uh the american soldier cemetery
over there and all that type of stuff
and um one of my podcast listeners sent
me
an email a couple months ago talking
about how
after he took the tour the next morning
he woke up early
and went down to omaha beach when there
was nobody there
you know maybe one guy with a dog and a
frisbee
right and he just sat there on the uh
on the on the beach and smoked a cigar
and i was like dude i gotta [ __ ] do
that right i gotta [ __ ] do that so i
got my cigar i take the tour and i got
that big stupid mercedes nine passenger
bus that they rented me because i wanted
a car one way
and as i've told you guys time and time
again on this podcast when you rent a
car one way you are getting the [ __ ]
ugly duckling the one that they can't
rent out you're getting the griswold
family truckster and that's what they
gave me for two [ __ ] people nine
passenger right
so i wake up the next morning
early nia's still sleeping
and um
you know my phone is dead
and i'm not going to take her phone
because i don't be like why did you take
my phone
i was looking for it
i didn't want to deal with that right
so what i have is i have this gps
that was this [ __ ] in about 2002.
i'm in another country i don't speak the
language
it's about eight o'clock in the morning
and i go out and i get in this [ __ ]
nine passenger bus
by myself and i start driving
and
i already can't get it to say omaha
beach i can't read half the signs and
i'm just laughing as i'm driving away
going i'm going to get lost
and i keep turning around every time i
make a left to turn around and i'm
rather than looking at a sign i'm trying
to look at something that stands out a
billboard or something and i'm trying to
remember like remember that [ __ ] game
simon
right
the little colors and it would go all
around a [ __ ] great game
great electronic game
one of the few that i was allowed to
have
my parents never gave us video games
never let us do any of that [ __ ] because
they thought it was going to affect our
studies you know
my dad's like you're not watching that
[ __ ]
but dad i want to play asteroids i said
hit the [ __ ] books
you know what's funny is i still flunked
everything in high school
so maybe he should have let me play miss
pac-man
[Music]
um i didn't flunk it but i was in you
know
if if my high school class was a batting
lineup i was batting eighth
right right before the catcher
um anyways
so uh
so i get in this van and i'm [ __ ]
laughing and i'm trying to feel my way
back to where the tour guide drove us
and you know every [ __ ]
20 seconds is a goddamn rotary
round and round and round you go and you
sped out the van and i have no [ __ ]
idea where i'm at
so i'm just laughing i'm like i don't
give a [ __ ] i know where the beach i
know the beach is in this direction i'm
just going in this direction and then i
know i go left
gosh
as the french people say i'm going left
and then i'm just gonna drive until i
see it and i'm going to get there i'm
going to smoke my cigar i'm going to
complete this [ __ ] mission right
and uh and then i'll deal with the fact
that i don't know how to get back
and that i have a flight to catch
you know early afternoon
so uh actually it wasn't even eight in
the morning it was like nine by the time
i got up or whatever so i kind of blew
the early morning part of it but i still
wanted to go smoke the cigar so i'm
driving and
this [ __ ] thing is just taking me
you know
i can't figure out how to input it i
can't there's no enter button i can't
i'm going omaha beach and i'm yelling at
the [ __ ] thing
and i'm screaming at about the rental
car people how can you rent this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] out and charge somebody
[ __ ] 20 francs a day for this goddamn
thing or euros whatever the [ __ ] they're
on
and
i'm driving down the road and i got the
radio on
because i'm trying to immerse myself in
the language that's what you're supposed
to do when you learn a new language you
just immerse yourself in it although i'm
sitting there speaking english which i
shouldn't be doing i should be going mad
zoot or whatever the [ __ ] i'm supposed
to be yelling
um
but i wasn't i was i was speaking in
english so anyways i had on this is the
point of the story
i had on french talk radio
and it was [ __ ] hilarious first of
all they're speaking 90 miles an hour
and i'm
just by the way they're talking you can
tell basically i don't know what they're
talking about but you can kind of figure
out like what's going on and somebody's
like you know
and then some other guy goes like
the other guy's like
so it says the guy said something and
the other guy goes you know what the
[ __ ] that and the other guy goes no no
i'm not saying i'm not saying it's a bad
thing i'm just you know i'm just saying
oh cleo what's up buddy you've been on
the podcast in a while no no no no no
get off the bed get off the bed
get off the bed sorry
gonna [ __ ] hit stop on the record
button so anyways these guys are going
back
so anyways i'm listening to this [ __ ]
and now i'm driving into fog i'm
completely [ __ ] lost and i'm
listening to these guys
and what's funny over there
is when people talk
and they're searching for a word they
don't go ah
because that's actually a word
like ila so you'd be like have
so you'd be going have
you wouldn't do that so what they do
they say is this this is my i think this
is what's going on so rather than going
ah
or um they go like e e e u r almost uh
and what so they kept doing that going
as i'm driving through the [ __ ] fog
and i'm laughing just going uh imitating
the [ __ ] as i'm trying to find this
beach and then you know like when you
try to make a point
in any language
you're like you know this guy is is is
is or you know these people what they
try to do is whatever you say like the
[ __ ] word like 15 times in a row so
that's what they kept going they kept
going like hey
and i'm driving in the fog
go going
doo doo
stupid [ __ ] french people i'm
screaming about them and the stupid
thing and long story short
this [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
atari
map quest whatever the [ __ ] you call it
makes me go left i'm going down these
farm roads
all right and now it literally feels
like it's 1944
and some germans are gonna come around
the corner with a motorcycle and a side
car i'm driving by
the uh the hedgerows
i'm getting to like dirt roads
and i'm just laughing i have no [ __ ]
idea
where i'm at it's foggy i'm on a road
that's so [ __ ] small like i literally
have to pull this bus over to let
somebody else go by
they give the wave over there by the way
and i'm just driving
driving my way through this [ __ ]
thing and i finally make it to the road
like an hour later and my flight is
leaving in two and a half hours i have
no [ __ ] idea how to get back
and i get to the place where i'm gonna
make the left to drive up to the beach
and it says road closed
you know
and you got to be sitting there going
bill
you know 3 000 people died that way that
day i mean
on that beach
they saw their mission through
they just kept coming and coming and
coming
until they [ __ ] met their objective
are you gonna let one little french
police
barricade
that says erect
or stop whatever the [ __ ] it says you're
gonna let that stop you
are you just gonna drive this nine
passenger van around it and use the fact
that you don't speak the language as a
goddamn excuse
[Music]
right
i pussied out
i was just like i got to go to the
[ __ ] airport i don't even know where
i'm at and i [ __ ] turned around
like the coward that cries in the
foxhole
so now i'm driving back into the fog
and dude it took me like [ __ ]
it took me like [ __ ] two hours
we almost missed our goddamn flight i'm
driving around rotary after [ __ ]
rotary
and i can't find this place and then
finally i came
in bayou they have like this old part of
town
you know they got all these you know
strip malls and strip malls but just
like just regular [ __ ]
place to get un sand beach
um
they got all that [ __ ] right but
then in the center of town they have
like the old school like like the old
part of town like old montreal
old vegas
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
so
i see this church
and i'm like i remember that [ __ ]
church my hotel is somewhere near that
church and there's a little brook
near it
so i drive back and it was the most
frustrating half hour of my life because
i knew
that i was near my [ __ ] hotel but i
just couldn't find the [ __ ] thing and
finally
i i found the brook
and what i had to do i had to just i
just got out of the van
and started walking around and then i
finally
and i'm walking up to people and i'm
going uh
uh excuse me
uh i was doing that i was going uh so
it's actually going excuse me
someone's going excuse me have
um
or has whatever i'm saying
i was like excuse me
uh
winston churchill hotel hotel day
winston churchill because that wasn't
even named my hotel but my hotel was
right next to it
and then it would be like
uh gonna say uh oh god damn it [ __ ] and
i it took me like five people
walking up to him
um and i finally was able to find the
brook and then i found it
and i saw him if there's my [ __ ]
hotel and then i just took this i had to
run back to the van and weave my way
around it
i'm freaking out knowing my wife's going
to be pissed at me
and i finally get to the hotel and uh we
got enough time to get to the airport i
[ __ ] go in the hotel room and she's
still sleeping
she's still sleeping
she's like hey baby
did you make it to the beach
and i was like no i couldn't find it
that stupid piece of [ __ ] map quest
[ __ ] thing from 1982
took me down a country road and she just
goes oh why didn't you just take my
phone honey
and that's the story
[Laughter]
um but anyways i'm keeping up with my my
french [ __ ]
uh i'm gonna try to uh
i don't know i gave up on the spanish
stuff i just
there's something about the french
language where i flunked it for three
years
in high school and it's familiar
and i and i feel like maybe through
learning french i can somehow learn
spanish i don't know a lot of you guys
are sitting there going [ __ ] you bill
you're never going to learn this [ __ ]
and you know what i thrive off of that
go [ __ ] yourselves i'm going to learn
how to speak it
and when i do i'm going to do an entire
podcast in french i'm from say
all right uh let's do some advertising
for this week uh e-voice everybody um
want your business to make more money
e-voice can help here's how when your
customers call you'll have your own
toll-free number professional greeting
dial by name directory and more
uh you'll sound like a fortune 500
company and really stand out from the
competitors evoice lets you give out
your number that rings wherever you are
you could be at your kids soccer game
you'll never miss a chance to grow your
business evoice even takes all your
voicemails transcribes them and sends
them to you instantly as a text or an
email couldn't be any more easier so you
can check uh voicemails before the
meeting ends so you don't look rude
e-voice is only 13 bucks a month and
right now my listeners can try e-voice
for absolutely free for 60 days
60 days that's right a 60-day free trial
don't put this off turn down the radio
get to a computer i guess mute this pod
podcast and set up your e-voice 60-day
free trial now so you can see what i
mean go to evoice.com promo code bill
that's evoice dot com promo code bill
all right the next one legalzoom
everybody modern technology is great
smartphones ipads and other gadgets make
it easy to do so many great things but
why is it that our lives seem to get
busier at the same time legal zone
getting philosophical here well when it
comes to getting the legal help you need
legalzoom provides a great solution that
works with your busy schedule let's face
it the legal system is complicated there
are better things you can do with your
time thankfully legalzoom is there for
you so if you're thinking about starting
a business forming an llc or getting a
trademark will or living trust legalzoom
gets the job done right you get a you'll
get the personal attention you need and
they'll help you take care of all the
details legalzoom's been helping
families and small business owners for
14 years and they received an a-plus
from the better business bureau call or
visit legalzoom today for an extra
discount you can enter bur b-u-r-r in
the referral box at checkout that's
legalzoom.com discount code burr
legalzoom provides legal help through an
independent attorneys through
independent attorneys and self-help
services but they are not a law firm go
to legalzoom.com enter discount code
burr b-u-r-r
there you are hey that was pretty good
reading for this week um
oh by the way uh
i've been obsessed
with um with german cars
ever since um
i went on that that d-day trip
you know and i looked at one of our
tanks
you know our tank basically if a chevy
chevette was a tank that's what the [ __ ]
we were rolling out
uh which once again
is i'm really starting to understand why
tom brokaw called them the greatest
generation because uh
i i couldn't even make it to omaha beach
in a [ __ ] mercedes-benz nine
passenger with [ __ ] satellite help
these tanks were compared to what the
germans had
it's unfucking believable so i i
actually you guys got to see this video
that i watched this week if you're into
cars
they basically show um them putting
together the engine that they stick in
one of their unbelievable cars
and this guy hand builds the entire
thing with the help of some
actually some really cool robots and you
know that i'm not into robots but what i
like about these robots is they're doing
the pain in the ass job that you don't
want to do like you know when you you
squeeze that that [ __ ] glue i guess
to basically i don't know if you're
sealing the head to the block
i thought there was a gasket there i
have no idea it was one of those deals
one of those deals but this [ __ ]
robot thing just it's got the
the sealer
and it [ __ ] goes right around the
edge and then when you get to a screw it
goes like around the rotary like me in
the bus and then just [ __ ] continues
on and it's perfect
and then you line up so basically the
guy puts the whole
glorious engine together and then in the
end he has his own seal with his name he
puts his [ __ ] name
on the engine
and i was like oh my god i got to get a
mercedes someday and then i looked up
how much they cost and i was like oh my
god i gotta rent a mercedes someday
i know you can get some of the smaller
ones but you know the one you [ __ ]
want
you know
you know the mercedes you want you don't
want to get those [ __ ] the lower end
ones [ __ ] those ones you want the one
that you're walking up to somebody opens
the door for you and you have a
briefcase handcuffed to your [ __ ]
wrist that's the model you want
like the one i looked up i'm like well
[ __ ] this what's the best one they got
so they're uh basically you know the
bmw's got the m's the m series the m5
the m6 the m3 and all that with mercedes
they have the amg so i'm like oh let me
check out it's a [ __ ] four-door sedan
they wanted 237 000 for this [ __ ]
thing
you know
and i was just like all right
well you know that was that was a that
was a fun fantasy
i mean they'll go buy a used one
from somebody getting a goddamn divorce
or some [ __ ] i don't know what but i i
definitely got to uh hopefully i'll
remember
maybe i'll make a note right now i'll do
that because i always say i'm going to
put that video up hey everybody
i'm putting a video up and uh guess what
it's going to be up on the website and
it never is if you guys just saw how i
just typed mercedes with my right hand
i'm left-handed
m-e-r-c-e-s
mercies
mercy
mercedes wait a minute
i put the din i swear to god am i do i
have also dyslexia m-e-r-c-e-d
yes that looks right right
mercedes video stupid
why do you have to insult yourself why
can't you love yourself and just tie a
string around your finger
um anyways
yes so i am back in the united states of
america and uh
i'm getting back to uh watching american
sports
and um
jesus christ my picks last week i swear
to god in the nhl what a [ __ ] train
wreck that was
that was like some paul versey [ __ ] i
went on there and i only picked one
upset
i really hope he hears that can you guys
please send that link to him like paul
like please send this entire section if
you can paul you're listening to this
i went i did what you did i went with
all the [ __ ] favorites
and i'm gonna give you my results right
now if you're listening
new jersey zone
dude i called it paul versi all right
flyers versus the rangers
i picked the [ __ ] flyers
that series is actually 1-1
boston detroit i picked the bruins that
series has won one
uh montreal i actually picked montreal
jesus christ where the [ __ ] are all my
losses oh yeah san jose los angeles i
picked los angeles i guess they're not
the favorites but i looked ah san jose
[ __ ]
they like win the president's trophy
every year then they [ __ ] they lose
usually in the first goddamn round i'm
not [ __ ] on the san jose shacks
come on down get mvp sports we got all
the jerseys we got the shacks the
steelers the chargers and more
um
i'll never forget that read every time i
say san jose shocks i always think about
mvp sports
in boston um
yeah so i just they just they they do it
every year i'm stating a fact all right
pittsburgh columbus i picked the uh the
penguins
that's 1-1
colorado minnesota pick minnesota
they're down 02. chicago st louis i
picked the blues i'm sorry i picked
chicago they're down 0-2
i don't know but anyways it's been a
hell of a [ __ ] uh
actually wait a minute let's go back
here was i that bad maybe i'm giving
versi a compliment
all right minnesota wild i picked them
they're down 0-2
blackhawks they're down 02.
i did pick the uh ducks
i picked the kings they're down 02.
a big tree i think i'm doing all right
look if the bruins win this series
and the [ __ ] penguins win that series
and the flyers win then i i think i'm
all right and then you know what i would
owe paul version apology
um anyways how great is the playoffs man
i swear to god if you're still watching
nba hoop i understand it it's a great
game to watch but come on why don't you
watch a real [ __ ] league
instead of the nba who's kidding who
if you really watch the nba i mean that
is the most manipulated [ __ ] sport
i mean i know it's all all of them are a
goddamn business i would say the nfl is
the least manipulated now i know a lot
of people don't like the new rules but
everybody's got to play by them but like
i've said this a zillion times but
everybody's got the [ __ ] seahawks
goddamn seahawks
just want a [ __ ] super bowl
that's great
when the [ __ ] are the mariners going to
be in a position where they can spend
enough money to compete with the red sox
and the yankees and give me a break it
ain't [ __ ] happening although they
just blew a bunch of money
on robinson canoe
paul verzi's man crush
um
they had the [ __ ] they what a bunch of
idiots they were didn't they learn
anything from the texas [ __ ] rages
you don't blow 200 million on a short
stop
then you have no money for pitching so
you're gonna blow 200 oh what if it's on
the other side of second base what's the
[ __ ] blow 200 million on this guy
so anyways
the uh yeah the nba is basically uh i
feel like the nba is like
it's like wrestling two years before
they they admitted that it's just was
all right
you know we're fake fighting but we're
really hurting each other
and then everybody was just like all
right cool you know we'll go with this
that's what they should do in the nba
just go look
they're really playing the games but
you know we got to make sure certain
teams get to a certain point in the
playoffs
so we can get the ratings we need so we
can all make our money
and uh we refuse to pay the referees
anything more than we're giving them
despite the fact that an nba official
has more power than any other official
in the four major sports
now i just paused there because i'm
waiting for all the [ __ ] [ __ ] sports
fans to be like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's true no other sport can you just
sit a [ __ ] guy down a star player you
can sit him down in the first quarter
give him two quick ones second quarter
give him that i've said this a zillion
[ __ ] times you can keep him on the
bench the whole goddamn game yeah you
can't keep tom brady on the bench
you'd have to kick him out for something
what is tom brady gonna do
that's gonna make you kick him out huh
you can what are you going to penalize
him for his dimple being too deep
right you're going to take out some
measuring things stick like when some
somebody has like a two curve to stick
and hockey you're not throwing them out
anyways i'm not saying you can't
manipulate the game but nowhere can you
manipulate it more than the [ __ ] nba
so i'm just saying come on over and
watch the [ __ ] hockey it's been
unbelievable so far
and uh the bruins
uh detroit series
is is shaping up to go seven games it's
been [ __ ] great uh the game one
um
i mean they just made us look old and
slow detroit is so goddamn fast and let
me ask you this when was the last time
you saw a detroit red wings team
where every pass wasn't taped to tape
like what 1994 i mean they're going on
like [ __ ]
17 years
the puck movement on that team is
[ __ ] unbelievable and that sook is
from another planet that goal that he
scored
to win game one it was so [ __ ] good i
couldn't even get mad
i mean it definitely uh took the wind
out of my sails but i was just like
jesus christ that was the thing of
[ __ ] beauty
um that backhand pass he had in game two
he's [ __ ] incredible
and uh so what anyways they basically
for those who weren't watching they um
they were just flying all around the ice
and we looked like we were like
a division two hockey team trying to
keep up with them so you knew what was
gonna happen all right game two we're
gonna get physical
and that's what we were able to do so
now game three uh
is coming up now they're going to adjust
you know to us getting physical with
them you know it's always hard after you
won a [ __ ] game
to um
you know to win that next game in the
playoffs because you know you won the
game so you're like i guess we keep
doing what we're doing
you basically have to wait to see the
other team's adjustments that's why i
love playoff series and uh
and that type of stuff so i know there's
a bunch of detroit redwood fans and
haters of the bruins fans right now you
probably have your face like a
centimeter away from your jesus christ
how long was that in europe like an inch
away from your [ __ ] uh millimeter
away from your uh your recording device
right now going is he gonna bring up
milan lucich and his piece of [ __ ] yes
move
absolutely
somebody said going i would love to hear
you defend milan lucy
he basically spared this guy
um
like i think he got half taint half ball
bag hopefully the guy's balls hopefully
milan's stick he basically
he hit the sweet spot of the ball bag
that causes both of your [ __ ] balls
to go sideways
like those side impact airbags just
[ __ ]
to the side
and then his stick came down before they
clang back together which still would
definitely hurt but if they're going to
clang back together you'd rather be ball
the ball rather than
both balls hitting the [ __ ] wood or
the uh whatever the [ __ ] a stick's made
out of now
that's the second time he's done that in
three [ __ ] weeks
and i can't defend it
i think he should have got suspended
i think it's a [ __ ] joke
that that was a five thousand dollar
fine
five thousand dollar fine so basically
what you're telling me
nhl is you're telling me that danny
dekaiser's balls
are worth no more than 2 500 each
is that what you're telling me i mean
you're you're basically [ __ ] with the
man's ability
to start a family
this goes beyond the game of hockey that
look you know what it is it's it's a new
move
i haven't seen anybody do that
consistently i've seen somebody while
somebody's looking at him you know
and it's the shaft of the stick
and they'll kind of [ __ ] bring it up
like that oh he acted it out you like
that don't [ __ ] bring it up
but to have a guy skating up the [ __ ]
ice not even looking at you and you come
there and you turn your stick in the
blade up
and give the guy a [ __ ] wood uppercut
to his taint and ball area i mean jesus
christ
i'll tell you
that that's that's some new forensic
[ __ ] right there
you know
actually you know you that's that's
actually the only person who knows what
that bruises looks like
is a guy in forensics
actually i got i got i got a bruised
ball bag and taint one time
i don't know if i ever told you guys
this story i was working in a warehouse
and we had a softball team
it was basically an excuse for people to
drink [ __ ] uh coors light and wine
coolers it was the 80s
the ladies did drink the wine coolers
and then when i played in the league it
was right before
you know wine coolers had just come out
so there was actually a few guys
having some out of a four pack
uh
and it was it was that
maybe that three-week window before it
closed
where your your entire manhood was
judged if you ever had a [ __ ] wine
cooler but there was when they first
came out you know bartles and james
these two [ __ ] cute old guys doing
these silly commercials that it was
actually yeah let me try this
you know
that was they that was like the zima
version of wine
so anyways
anyways whatever i'm on base
i'm trying to go first to third on some
[ __ ] single to right
and my boss is on third base and the
ball comes in oh it came in from left
field so i must have been on second base
i never had any wheels so there's no
[ __ ] way i was trying to go first to
third on something that's left so i'm
running into second and i come in
standing up
and
they threw the ball was maybe it was the
center field because they threw it to
the outside a third base so he's
basically he's reaching over on the
into foul territory
and he backhanded
backhand how did he do it yeah he
backhanded it and then swooped up
to try to tag me
and i came in standing up
and he [ __ ] with the ball in the web
of his glove
went [ __ ] for what
to my [ __ ] undercarriage
and i remember standing on third base
waiting for the pain
you know like it didn't happen at first
and then immediately i'm thinking of
that eddie murphy bit that he did on one
of his specials where when you get
hitting the ball so bad there's that
delay
and then the p oh then yeah
that's usually a medium hit if you get
hitting the balls really bad you just go
oh and you go down
but if there's there's that light to
medium hit
where you get hit
and it there's a delay in the pedal that
the penalty the the paint
um
i don't know eddie murphy did a [ __ ]
phenomenal bid on it so anyways and it
never came and i'm standing there
and i'm sitting there waiting for people
to start giving me [ __ ] to be like dude
you just got hit in the balls and you
didn't feel any pain how small are they
right
and
it wasn't until like [ __ ]
like two three days later i'm in the
shower
right
and i'm cleaning myself and all of a
sudden i just [ __ ]
i don't know how i you know how the [ __ ]
do you look at your taint i don't know i
was washing my ball bag and i saw a
little bit of color
right
and i looked down and i swear to god the
back half of my sack right to the taint
was like
popsicle purple
all right
and i didn't even feel that so i can't
even imagine
what [ __ ]
poor danny dakar's
ball bag and [ __ ] taint look when he
took a piece of lumber
i mean it's just completely and i might
say this milan lucich
he had up until this point other than
just the haters that don't like him
because he's a classic power forward
that can score goals and beat the [ __ ]
out of anybody on your team if he
chooses
right
and i don't want to hear any of you guys
going like oh boy victor he's back down
the [ __ ]
who the [ __ ] was the goon the canadians
had back in the day he was actually one
of the uh uh i shouldn't say goon he was
one he made it an art form charles uh uh
george larocque
he's like why doesn't he fight that guy
and it's just like well
okay we're trying to win a hockey game
here stupid
so we're supposed to have a [ __ ]
all-star
square off with the goon
okay
keep calling him a goon square off with
the goddamn artist
of fighting
fighting a martial artist on skates he's
supposed to fight this guy
all right i'm not saying he would have
won but he couldn't hold held his own
he's a [ __ ] big guy
but he's risking injury and he's gonna
be sitting in the penalty box we don't
have him for five [ __ ] minutes and
you don't have george lark it's stupid
it's [ __ ] stupid that's like people
yesterday was giving me [ __ ] on twitter
asking why chara didn't fight that guy
that he was a foot taller than
that guy was trying to goad him into
dropping the gloves so he sits in the
penalty box and anybody who [ __ ] says
that char is a [ __ ] because he didn't
fight that guy you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you don't understand the game i
don't care how many [ __ ] games you
watched
it's a dano chara
arguably
still the best defenseman in the league
if not he's top two or three
so he's gonna drop the gloves with the
forward
and then go sit down and maybe get an
extra two
we're an entirely different team when
that guy's in the box you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you saw him laughing at the guy going
all right you drop him first
even then that would have been stupid so
anyways lou cheech
he only had one bad incident as far and
now granted i'm also prejudiced because
i'm a bruins fan was when he he [ __ ]
took a run at uh ryan miller
i hope i'm getting these names right
dude i'm still jet lagged that didn't
sound right when i said it reggie miller
ryan miller um
so he had that one
everybody has their one i got pissed and
i got far stated blah blah but now he's
got that and he's got two
spearings of the undercarriage so i
think for milan to get his rep back
he's going to have to be like lady bing
for the next seven years but i i think
that those two they're going to haunt
him for a while you can't [ __ ] do
that
you can't do that and that's a goddamn
shame
that the nhl
said that poor danny dekaiser's [ __ ]
balls are only worth 2 500 each i mean
come on
those guys at pawn shop would have given
you more [ __ ] money for those and
those guys don't pay
[ __ ]
hey can i get 2 500 for my balls
and then that bald-headed guy would be
like he'd be like how much do you really
want
2500 each you [ __ ] i hate that
everybody's a [ __ ] on the on that
[ __ ] show when he comes walking in
you come in with that whatever you got
and he's like oh yeah it looks great
what do you want for it no matter what
you say can i get one cent for this he's
a how much do you really want
his [ __ ] joke that's what i want [ __ ]
oh now it's two cents
um anyways that's why i stopped watching
that show
there's something about the way that
they do that that i don't enjoy yet i
can watch fast and loud and i think it's
absolutely [ __ ]
hilarious watching uh
richard rawlings bust those people down
there's just something i don't know the
way he does it it's so goddamn funny if
you guys watch any of the new episodes
where he went up and he met some guy
named so-and-so six-pack magoo whatever
his [ __ ] name in the middle of
minnesota
and the guy's shit-faced
and he gives rich's buddy literally a
jar of moonshine that that guy starts
drinking i forget what the [ __ ] they
what were they trying to buy
oh a 57 chevy
is that what it was was that the one
with the dent in it i think he got it
from that guy
so he's trying to bust the guy down to
like 1500 bucks for this and it is it is
a hunk of [ __ ] but he but it's a 57
chevy so he knows that you know he can
flip this thing
and this guy's hammered and he wants
1800 bucks and richard won't go above
1500 so the guy breaks out some dice
and they roll the dice on the hood of
the car i mean right there i mean it's
just come on
that's [ __ ] america right there
by the way he lost he had to pay him
1800 bucks but still he got a 57 for
1800 bucks it was a good i'm i'm totally
on a tangent here
um
so anyway so there you go detroit
redwing fans and everybody else and i
want you to remember this
all right you myopic [ __ ] when somebody
on your team does something filthy
don't be that douche in the sports bar
who j who just blindly defends your
[ __ ] team if somebody on your team
does a piece of [ __ ] move you got to
call them you got to call it out and say
it's a piece of [ __ ] moving that was an
unbelievable [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] move
he should have got suspended and and
like
come on
my balls are worth more than 2 500 bucks
each and i'm not i'm not in the playoffs
i'm not even in the league i play pickup
hockey
okay and if you [ __ ] hit me in the
nuts hard enough
all right when i go to sue you i'm not
suing you for five grand
all right so there we go
there we go um we are well into the
podcast here the podcast
um oh oh hey billy redface
has got to do some stand-up comedy here
because i have not done any stand-up
comedy since i uh
i did the uh the all-in i hosted the
all-in tour down in logo
and um
so i'm going to shake the rust off i got
a bunch of [ __ ] i want to talk about
because i'm doing some gigs this week in
uh portland oregon
mon not oregon portland maine sorry
montpelier uh vermont
and albany new york i believe that those
are the three gigs i'm doing this
weekend i could probably go to my
podcast my website
maybe get that information for you i
could probably do something like that be
organized but that then again then if i
did that it would not be the monday
morning podcast now would it
um speaking of uh podcast uh the
wonderful all things comedy
uh podcast network that me al madrigal
and some friends of ours have started
uh we actually we got some new people
that are coming aboard doug stanhope's
going to be coming aboard
uh
we got the uh and we got um dean edwards
hosting
the the father mukhen the father mucking
protocol how do you not listen to that
podcast the father mucked protocol where
he talks about the do's and don'ts
and what's been done
all right if dean edwards name sounds
familiar that's because you've seen him
on uh
colin ferguson snl cast member or now an
mtv2s hit the guy code uh he also does
spot on impressions
he does eddie murphy bernie mac don
cheadle chris rock
he does a good impression of me
check it out at the all things comedy
network the father mucked protocol um
actually i don't know if i was supposed
to announce doug stanhope yet i probably
just [ __ ] that up
but there's rumors that he's coming
aboard how about that huh
little teaser
all right let's read a little more
advertising then we'll get into the uh
the question for this week oh also check
out all things comedy uh tom segura's
new uh special completely normal it's
[ __ ] hilarious
and on and for those who live out in l.a
the next um all things comedy
comedy show out here the thing that we
do every month so we can pay for our
studios is going to be at the bootleg
theater
and uh yours truly will be on it along
with neil brennan
and a host of other uh all things comedy
people and uh we're bringing the lumber
that night so come on down i think the
tickets are like 15 bucks help us pay
for the studio so we can keep uh we'll
make you laugh there you go all right
stamps.com everybody when you think
about the oh and by the way that show's
april
29th my dog's dreaming
listen my dog's dreaming
do you hear that
oh now she's not gonna do it
she just went
i wonder what they [ __ ] have
nightmares about i think they're just
like us like they just know what they
know and they just [ __ ]
they just have nightmares that [ __ ]
thing sleeps all goddamn day
my dog's been jet-lagged since i got it
um
all right stamps.com everybody when you
think about the best time to go to the
post office you're probably guessing
before work after work or during lunch
wrong that's when it's the most crowded
everyone's going to be there at that
time the truth is there is no convenient
time to go to the post office and that's
why you need stamps.com stamps.com
stamps.com access all the services of
the post office right from your desk buy
and print official us postage for any
letter or package using your computer or
printer
they just hand it and then just hand it
to your mail carrier so easy or your
postman
oh that's why they didn't say it because
they don't want to be sexist or post
woman your mail carrier and unlike the
post office stamps.com is open 24 7 with
no lines so you can get your mailing and
shipping done whenever you want whenever
it's convenient for you i use stamps.com
to send out all my t-shirts all my
posters all my dvds that for some reason
i'm still trying to sell after shows
um and if i can use it anybody can
because i'm a [ __ ] right now use my
last name burr for this special offer no
risk trial plus 110 bonus offer that
includes a digital scale and up to 55
dollars free postage don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in burr burr that
stamps dot com enter bur
all right and lastly but not leastly
dollar shave club everyone nothing feels
better than that first shave with a
fresh blade right
well some things do but they involve
lubricant other than that
um it's smooth it's closed and the blade
is as sharp as it's ever going to be it
feels fantastic
but thanks to the big shaves company's
ridiculous prices you can't afford to
use a fresh blade every week
um listen i'm gonna get involved in your
money but a lot of you can't so you drag
that dull ass blade across your face for
two three ten weeks who knows depends on
how broke you are why do you do that to
yourself jesus christ bill is there a
solution maybe because the only thing
more painful than shaving with an old
blade is shelling out 30 bucks for a
pack of new ones it's a complete ripoff
well if you want to enjoy a fresh blade
uh fresh pack of blades every week but
you don't want to take out a second
mortgage on your house there you gotta
join dollarshaveclub.com for just a
couple bucks a month
dollarshaveclub.com ships the highest
quality blades you can get right to your
goddamn door
all right seriously only six bucks for
the best quality blades you can get so
every week yours truly i can pop in a
fresh blade and treat myself to an
amazing shave it's incredible it's long
overdue thank god for
dollarshaveclub.com you get amazing
quality blades in the mail for a couple
of bucks and you treat yourself to a
brand new blade every every single week
aren't you worth that isn't your face
worth that
that guy's balls are only worth 2500 a
whack can't you treat your face
to a little bit of luxury hundreds of
thousands of guys have upgraded their
shaving with dollarshaveclub.com and you
know what i'm one of them and i'm loving
it now it's your turn shave time shave
money dollarshaveclub.com
okay
all right let's get into the uh
some of the emails here for this week
all right
caught cheating
hey they have freckles the clown i'm a
married guy in my mid-30s i don't want
to bore everyone with the details but i
recently got cheated got caught cheating
on my wife with the 25 year old lady
the affair went on for about four months
and the truth is i really started to
like this girl after getting caught and
spending a few nights in a hotel my wife
graciously suggests
that we work up with that we work on our
marriage
and try to put this mess behind us
we have two small children so all logic
points to me agreeing to get the help we
need and to move on with our marriage
the only problem is that i can't get
this other girl out of my mind
these women are two polar opposites of
each other my wife
a professional more conservative woman
and the other girl is a 25 year old
party girl
i know what the clear answer is but how
do i snap out of this and put this other
girl out of my mind
all right this is a very simple one sir
first of all
your wife is a saint
all right that she's gonna take you back
and i'm not judging you all right i am a
man we've all been there
all right she is a saint
that she's gonna [ __ ] take you back
all right
so you gotta treat her like that one and
secondly what do you do how do you get
this girl out of your mind easy you wake
up in the morning
you walk into a bathroom you close the
door and you'll rub one out to her and
then you get on with your [ __ ] day
all right
go in there close the door rub one out
when you're done rubbing one out it's
just gonna hit you
what am i out of my [ __ ] mind listen
how you describe you know these women
they're two polar opposites my wife is a
professional more conservative woman and
the other girl is a 25 year old party
girl why don't you just say it
your wife is the kind of girl you marry
and this other girl is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right
dude any it's not worth it just [ __ ]
just
get it out of you i'm telling you
if you're any sort of an intelligent
human being the second you rub one out
you're going to be thinking i don't want
to call that other girl what am i a
[ __ ] idiot you're going to look at
your kids what the hell was i thinking
all right other than that if you don't
you're an idiot
all right because this is what's going
to happen sir you're going to lose your
wife your kids are going to hate you
you're going to lose your house you're
going to end up on a futon in a studio
apartment and that 25 year old party
girl is going to move on to somebody
else and you're going to be left there
with your dick in your hand
so both scenarios you end up with your
dick in your hand would you like to do
it in a four bedroom house or a [ __ ]
studio apartment
with empty chinese food containers all
around as you cry yourself to sleep
wondering what the [ __ ] happened
jesus
i gave him the lumber there didn't i huh
that was a little cheats there i gave
him the [ __ ] stick between the balls
there
um
all right next one
i am a hideous human being dear bill
i'll be straight to the point i am 25
years old and i have been a closet
homosexual for as long as i can remember
well dude you're gay so you were gay the
second you were born that's like me
being i'm a straight as long as i can
remember i guess you've been in the
closet is what you're trying to say i
don't you confuse me maybe you're right
maybe this is another example of me
being dumb maybe i read the sentence
wrong who knows who cares let's continue
sentence number three
i come from a strict asian immigrant
family and my parents would commit
suicide
if they found out about my orientation
you know i got scared when i saw the
first you basic you know orientation if
you take off the shun and put the l
there that was the word that i thought
oriental was coming on and i was gonna
get in trouble here
um
therefore
i've been committing petty crimes for
the past few years to get into jail so i
could pursue and nurture my
homosexuality [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i'm calling [ __ ] i'll
answer this
but i'm calling [ __ ] on this one
but there is something i got to tell you
though this is a very unique lie
so this could actually be true
you know what i'm going to go with this
like it's true
just in case
it is true and i don't want to be yet
another person
turning my back on this person all right
so here we go recently i was locked up
after i took three tabs of acid and i
don't really remember how i got into the
can
when i became sober during my trip i saw
a thousand dog bites
oh when you were tripping you saw a
thousand dog bites at me from every
direction and it was the worst drug
experience of my life
that's why i wasn't surprised when i
woke up in jail anyway i was quite
relieved to be away from society until
eight hours later i was released by my
parents the cops called them while i was
tripping in jail my question is if it's
better to be in jail happy and away from
society or an unhappy envi individual
that satisfies his parents and social ex
oh if it's better dude
what are you doing
if this is actually true come on man you
you got to be who you are all right and
uh i think every day
i don't know where you live in the world
but every single day uh
i i just feel like it's that scales are
tipping in the more
enlightened
favorable direction and you know what
you can become a part of that tipping of
the scale
um
seeing that that that kid who's going
into the nfl when he talked about i read
that story how when he finally came out
to his teammates and he felt like a
cinder block came off his chest i know
the feeling of having carrying something
around i don't know to that [ __ ]
level
so
i don't think you're gonna regret it
all right your parents aren't gonna
[ __ ] kill themselves
it might take them a while
to come around
all right
but if they don't
you know what [ __ ] them
okay
i think they will because at the end of
the day you're their kid all right but
what the [ __ ] do i know but at the end
of the day there
every kid at the end of the day has to
make a break with their parents on some
level where your philosophies do not
line up with theirs and if you're truly
going to pursue what's going to make you
happy in life there has to be the
cutting you know the metaphorical
cutting of the umbilical cord and you
have to be like you know what [ __ ] them
i know when i was a little kid to me
they were gods and i wanted their
approval and at the end of the day i now
realize that they're human beings and
they
have their flaws
and what they want me to do does not fit
in with what i want to do and and if
you're not hurt anybody which you're not
dude
what do you think you think you're gonna
go to jail and find love
i mean that it's not a you're not
exactly going
with some healthy [ __ ] people that's
like that would be like if a woman
wanted to find a good boyfriend and she
[ __ ] went to a place where uh guys
were locked up for abusing women you
know what i
mean those are some uh yeah
you can find a better boyfriend than
that just go to a gay bar
i would say you know or whatever
i don't pretend to know what the [ __ ]
that's bad that's like me say to a woman
hey you want to meet a good guy go to a
bar
whatever
we've reached the end of my
intelligence on this topic we probably
did about five minutes ago but i'm too
dumb to realize it but dude
if this is real
i'm treating it real
although it's so [ __ ] crazy i don't i
don't
i don't know
don't do that all right if if this is
actually true i'm choosing to believe it
don't [ __ ] do that all right
for the love of god
just [ __ ] of doubt i don't know how you
would do it
i you just got to send them down just
say it just get it out there and then
you set it and then it's out there
yeah you know i don't i don't know what
to do after that
you know what why don't you go
meet a gay guy i'm sure he can [ __ ]
give you some advice why are you asking
me
why am i yelling at you i got frustrated
because i don't have the answers i feel
bad for you if it's true all right i
hope it works out don't [ __ ] go to
jail
all right
being gay is great
you're [ __ ] in great shape you got
all this disposable income
and wherever you're living you're making
the the [ __ ] property value go up
it's a lot of advantages
you know
anyways
let's plow ahead
where are we 54 minutes okay x won't
sell house
dear bill
big fan met you in jacksonville a while
back i have a quick question for you my
ex-fiance and i were together for four
and a half years why the [ __ ] did you
buy a house with somebody you're not
married to
all right that that doesn't help you but
for anybody listening do not buy a house
do not live with somebody you're not
gonna marry do not buy a house with
somebody you're not gonna if you're not
married don't do that [ __ ]
anyways during the relationship she re
she remained loyal
while i was deployed to the middle east
and upon my return i used my saved up
money to buy a house
with her near the beach
oh my god if this [ __ ] woman
is is gonna somehow make a claim to your
house that you bought
with your serving for our country
putting your life on the line money
this would be a new level of whoredom
is that a new word i think uh whoredom
all right
that might not even be i know it's a new
word but that might not be the proper
usage of it already
which would be very uh apropos for the
type of [ __ ] [ __ ] i am all right
hang on a second
where the hell am is okay it was her
dream house
and i felt that if the deployment didn't
ruin us that nothing would well i was
wrong we decided to split and i tried to
be amiable
did i say that right and let her keep
the house
if she could pay me the closing cost of
about eight grand this is what guys do
they just want to cut bait and [ __ ]
leave
women got that [ __ ] they borrow in
she agreed all right
why did you do that she agreed and i
moved you bought the [ __ ] house did
she kick in for it
maybe i'm being too hard on her
i don't know she agreed and i moved back
home to new jersey to start a new life
it's been nearly a year and she's has
stalled every effort to get this
resolved when a contract was finally in
place she decided it needed some
amendments to protect herself that
basically left me with less money than
we agreed and getting her a house worth
150 grand for 8 000 bucks dude i swear
to [ __ ] god if i read one more of
these [ __ ] stories
all right if you're some [ __ ] woman
all right and you you host one of these
shows where you're always talking about
the [ __ ] that men do how about you
balance it out the way i balanced it out
saying that lou cheats did a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] move why don't you bring
this [ __ ] up this is ridiculous
he goes i threw out the contract and
contract contacted a realtor to list the
house there you go
she's refused to sell
and her name is on the title because i'm
a [ __ ] idiot long story short after i
threaten a lawsuit a mysterious man who
called himself a family friend emailed
me and asked
to act as the facilitator for the deal
between the two of us my ex dude don't
give in to that my ex has not been
involved
since and this guy is a real [ __ ] who is
only out for her my cousin who is a
lawyer is guiding me through the process
but i need some advice from you on how
to resolve this issue i just found out
that the family friend is my new ex's
new boyfriend i could have told you that
my question is how do i
let them know that i know i'm like a
serial killer who needs to be caught
what i'm like a serial killer who needs
to be caught her man
caught here man what
typo there i can't resist them
thinking i don't
i guess no anymore i thought a nice joke
about her having herpes would be a good
start
i joke that she was too selfish to even
give me that any feedback or advice on
the podcast would really be appreciated
um
i usually say cut bait but [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] that
uh you have two options here
and i don't want to tell you what the
second one is
uh the first one is well you have three
fight this which i would
walk away from it which i wouldn't
and number three
uh would involve a convenient accident
that happened to the house
[Laughter]
but even then then she'd probably fight
you for the uh
ah who could they figure out you started
the fire don't don't i shouldn't even
brought that up
listen
this is what you got to do you just got
to accept the fact
that you're in for a long fight here and
that lawyers are going to get most of
the money but that [ __ ] is not going to
get the house now
to go that route
oh god i don't want to tell you to quit
but my world i would just be like look
you want 150 000 [ __ ] dollar house
just take the [ __ ] house
free and clear
um
it cost you 150 grand to get rid of this
[ __ ] devil woman that's going to take
that new guy down
she's going to take that guy down
this i mean granted i only heard your
side of the story
all right and i'm taking this as the
truth and if this is the truth that that
that's not the that's not
you don't want that devil woman in your
[ __ ] life that is some evil [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um
uh okay i gotta walk away from the story
because it's it's actually making me
[ __ ] mad and i don't have a dog in
the fight here
what i'm doing is i am inserting myself
into the story who i would be in this
[ __ ] story oh
jesus dude you're young you're young
get into the best shape of your life hit
on women out of your [ __ ] league and
then treat her like a [ __ ] queen
marry her and then walk by this [ __ ]
someday on the street that's that's what
i would do
all right
oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
how long to wait for sex short and
simple
adolf hitler
i know what that means i'm 26 and i
started dating a girl a lady
we got to talking about doing the dirty
oh jesus and she said she doesn't want
to be sexual for a while probably
because you say hey what do you what do
you say we do the dirty yeah i mean i
got my [ __ ] balls over here with a
stick attached to it i like to uh
put your seats uh per se
uh memoizel
uh my question is how long is too long
to wait i don't want to pressure her i
want her to feel comfortable but the
same time i'm 26 what do you think also
side note what do you think about the
lucy's
uh cupch i already went on that
um
all right uh
i don't want to pressure her
dude you don't give a [ __ ] about this
woman
get out of the relationship
you just want a banger
you want a [ __ ]
26 i got my [ __ ] balls they're full
over here what am i supposed to do oh by
the way what'd you think about that
thing that guy did in the hockey game
i'm supposed to give a [ __ ] you couldn't
even get through this goddamn question
the
[ __ ] side track this is what i do i'd
break up with her
all right she doesn't want to have sex
with you no means no
don't pressure her jesus christ you want
to have sex with her while she's sobbing
you [ __ ] weirdo
look
you don't give a [ __ ] that's a goddamn
phone buzzing there you don't give a
[ __ ] about this woman
okay
you don't break up with her okay and go
find some woman that's going to jump on
your dick because that's what you want
right now in your life because you're
26.
all right there you go he says thank you
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself same to you
sir
same to you
jesus that phone never stop ringing
clean
why won't it stop ringing
it's actually my wife's phone hey nia
your phone is buzzing and it's not going
to stop
it's just like the illuminati calling
but they they they [ __ ] go around
your
what is it doing
it's buzzing oh it's your alarm
oh all right how you doing
i already pissed
huh
i'm actually wrapping up the podcast
right now
all right
there you go
that's the kind of interaction you live
for
um but you know what that you have to
while you get to know the person you
live with that means i'm watching
something interesting
you douche
um all right well that's the podcast for
this week everybody uh i hope you
enjoyed it i hope it made you laugh the
beginning part of the [ __ ] week
um i am going to be why don't we look it
up here
why don't we look this [ __ ] up here see
where the [ __ ] i'm gonna be
where am i gonna be oh
billy freckles
billboard.com oh by the way everybody uh
if you if you're gonna think if you're
thinking about buying something on
amazon.com and you would also like to
donate to this podcast
go to the podcast page on billboard.com
and uh click on the amazon amazon banner
right it'll take you right to amazon
doesn't cost you any extra money they
kick me a little uh don't rain me there
for uh send you there if you don't want
to do it i understand
you know your fingers got better things
to do than do it extra two clicks all
right let's get on with the shows here
william uh william burr here is going to
be at the flynn theater in oh i'm not
montpelier in burlington vermont
burlington coat factory come on down and
get yourself a windbreaker i'm going to
be at the burlington uh
well the flynn theater in burlington
vermont
on april 25th
april 26th i'm going gonna be at the uh
state theater in portland maine
for two shows they added a late show i
guess and then on april 27th i'm gonna
be at the palace theater
in albany new york
there you go so please come out to the
show that's the end of the podcast oh
cleo
get up here buddy come on up here
come on
jesus christ now you won't get up on the
bed come here
come on come on there you go
what's up buddy
[ __ ] pee
making me want to work out all right
that's a podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves au revoir
something else in french i'll talk to
you next week go [ __ ] yourselves